started my journey as a cloud engineer I
think five and a half years back uh so
in that process I started with
development and I did it for like couple
of months and then I slowly moved to the
deployment part of it and I started
liking creating infrastructures
automating them creating cicd pipelines
and automating things in Python shell
and whatever way it is possible because
uh I'm making things easier was one of
the thing that I loving about it and
then I moved to a different organization
where where I worked as a Solutions
engineer so understanding customer
problems like suggesting them a good
architectural overview and how they can
make or use the product in a better way
and after that I moved to a different
organization where I worked as a senior
devops engineer and my entire
responsibility was to like automate the
things and make processes easier uh how
we can roll out the updates frequently
without any Interruption and making sure
the reliability and highly High
availability as well so after that in my
current organization I'm working as a
consultant